on reste presque dans cette thématique
encore de l'alimentaire avec nos invités
ce soir Christelle Badji bonsoir à vous
Julie Boutillier et Julie Vieira bonsoir
également puisque vous êtes du lycée
hôtellerie tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines plus
précisément vous êtes en charge du
dispositif passerait l'universitaire et
puis face à vous deux des élèves qui ont
bénéficié de ce dispositif vous suivez
la formation tourisme c'est bien ça ce
dispositif passerel universitaire ça a
fonctionné comment et ça s'adresse à qui
ça sert à quoi en fait ça s'adresse à
des étudiants qui souhaitent se
réorienter vers les métiers de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
tourisme qui ont tous obtenus leur bac
qui ont parfois démarré une formation à
l'université qui désire en fait se
réorienter en cours d'année et donc ils
font appel à nous poursuivre une
formation de trois mois au lycée
hôtelier donc ils étaient décroché leurs
études ou qu'ils ne se soient pas
épanouis en tout cas à l'université ils
peuvent ensuite donc faire cette
formation c'est une mise à niveau et
ensuite ces BTS Hôtellerie Restauration
alternance et BTS Tourisme par la voie
initiale pour être précis sur les
formations
bon c'est une formation accélérée qui
qui peut permettre en fait à des
étudiants qui n'ont pas suivi en cursus
en hôtellerie restauration d'aller
directement sur un BTS Hôtellerie
Restauration donc avec le CFA
trajectoire en apprentissage ou aussi
donc suivre après la formation BTS
tourisme au lycée hôtelier ou bien
également nous avons depuis cette année
une mention complémentaire accueille
réception qui est également le troisième
débouché possible mais la mise à niveau
se fait assez facilement ils sont pas
trop perdus parce que ça change
complètement de l'univers quand on passe
des propriétés aux salles de
restauration au service ou pour le
tourisme il est vrai que non en général
ça se passe plutôt bien puisqu'ils ont
quand même une période de stage durant
la passerelle donc qui leur permet voilà
de
d'aller directement sur le terrain pour
se frotter à la réalité du du métier et
en général ça se passe très bien je
parlais de l'Université de ceux qui ont
décroché aussi parce que ce n'est pas
que les étudiants uniquement qui sont à
l'université des jeunes qui sont
conseillés par exemple par la Mission
Locale
donc on a des jeunes qui postulent à la
formation après avoir travaillé pendant
un ou deux ans peut-être un restaurant
en restauration où ça peut être tout
autre dans un tout autre domaine en fait
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être inscrit à
l'université pour pour faire cette
formation mais la plupart des étudiants
le sont en fait en majorité la sixième
promotion qui va débuter dépôt des
dossiers jusqu'au moment parce que c'est
27 mars le début tout à fait donc en
fait on a reçu déjà pas mal de dossiers
on boucle en fait la le recrutement
normalement c'est samedi à l'occasion de
la Journée Portes Ouvertes on reçoit les
derniers candidats qui voudraient en
bénéficier on va demander peut-être tout
de même aux Julie alors je suis désolé
comme vous avez le même prénom ça va
être un petit peu compliqué quels sont
vos parcours respectifs avant d'arriver
dans ces formations tourisme vous
suiviez quelle formation avant ben moi
j'étais en fac de théâtre à la Sorbonne
et en fait j'ai fait deux mois là-bas et
j'ai arrêté j'ai travaillé et en fait
c'est lors des portes ouvertes de
l'année dernière de du lycée où j'ai
connu la passerelle universitaire on en
a parlé et puis je me suis dit bah
pourquoi pas parce que je savais que je
voulais faire un BTS Tourisme et donc
histoire de me remettre dans le bain et
c'était une très bonne expérience ce qui
vous concerne alors pour ma part j'étais
pareil j'ai fait deux mois en fac de
Lettres Modernes donc à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc après ça
m'a pas plu donc j'ai arrêté ensuite
donc j'ai travaillé comme je l'ai toute
l'année et j'ai connu donc la passerelle
universitaire grâce au dispositif à Brie
donc qui est en place à la fac et donc
ils m'ont réorienté donc vers la
passerelle donc j'ai fait la passerelle
ça n'a pas été trop compliqué quand vous
êtes arrivés pour la transition
l'adaptation s'est fait assez facilement
on a eu des très bons profs aussi et non
c'est facile
on s'est retrouvé dans une classe où on
était 17 il me semble et tout le monde
était comme nous tout le monde avait eu
donc voilà on était un peu tous perdu et
du coup ça nous a beaucoup rassuré je
pense donc pour pour continuer la
passerelle donc avec succès on avait des
parcours très différents en fait les uns
les autres et c'est vrai qu'on sait tous
motivés pour cette passerelle
ce changement d'univers au-delà de ça
c'est aussi un changement de une méthode
de travail le cadre est plus strict plus
rigoureux c'est plus rigoureux mais en
ce qui me concerne c'est ce que je
voulais parce que moi la fac c'était
peut-être un peu trop libre pour moi
donc c'est vrai que être recadré un peu
dans un lycée donc c'est vrai que
c'était c'était motivant je disais tout
à l'heure sixième année pour ce
dispositif pourquoi vous êtes allé
chercher justement des jeunes avec ces
sceptiques de profil par exemple qui
n'étaient pas destinés à l'origine à
suivre cette formation je pense que
c'est une volonté de la région et puis
de trouver des des opportunités pour les
ce qu'ils appellent les décrocheurs ou
ses étudiants en fait qui après le bac
ne savent plus trop quoi faire ou
démarre une formation à l'université on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
qui parviennent pas à obtenir leur
licence en fait qui décrochent en cours
d'année donc le CFA trajectoire donc et
le lycée hôtelier de Saint-Quentin
élu en partenariat avec l'Université de
50 ans donc on met en place ce
dispositif et vu que ça fonctionne
plutôt bien puisque les premiers
résultats
donc on a déjà eu des étudiants qui ont
qui sont allés jusqu'au bout qui va
passer leur BTS et au niveau des
résultats c'est satisfaisant de voir
très satisfaisant donc ça nous incite à
poursuivre cette formation
qui qui
travaillent et d'autres ont même
poursuivi leurs études après en licence
pour certains donc c'est plutôt positif
les gens qui arrivent 100% c'est pas
tout à fait mais voilà ça on n'a pas on
n'a pas vraiment de de problèmes de
réussite avec ses étudiants là bien au
contraire en fait c'est souvent des
étudiants qui dans nos classes sont très
motivés parce que justement ils ont ils
ont eu cette petite formation de trois
mois qui qui les conforte dans leur
choix et en général ils ont tendance à
entraîner la classe avec eux donc c'est
plutôt positif et par rapport au cadre
on entendait tout à l'heure parler de
l'université par exemple l'étudiante qui
nous disait que justement il fallait
peut-être pour elle pour vous en tout
cas ce cadre un peu plus stricte c'est
facile de leur apprendre ça aussi de
leur montrer que c'est
de la même manière dans un lycée
d'hôtellerie de tourisme oui ça se passe
plutôt bien parce qu'en général ils ont
un peu tous la même remarque que la u
Julie à savoir besoin de d'encadre plus
strict et donc ça leur convient plutôt
bien donc on n'a pas de problème en
général et puis on sélectionne quand
même pas mal à l'entrée de la passerelle
on reçoit tous les candidats et il est
vrai qu'on accorde beaucoup d'importance
à l'acidité au fait que que le profil
soit sérieux et on essaie vraiment de
retenir les candidats les plus sérieux
la sélection c'est comment dossier
entretien exactement dossier plus
entretien voilà c'est un dossier et un
entretien assez long ou on explique
vraiment un détail puisque c'est assez
novateur c'est pas très très fréquent
cette formation elle existe peu donc on
leur explique en détail vraiment en quoi
cela consiste pour qu'après il soit il
soit bien au clair et qui sachent
vraiment pourquoi il pourquoi il démarre
la formation et donc voilà on s'assure
en général de d'une classe assez
homogène et plutôt motivée et comment
vous êtes perçu par les autres étudiants
ne sont pas passés par le dispositif
passerelle
public vous venez pas de vous avez pas
commencé de la même manière en tout cas
la plupart ils sont pas au courant en
fait et c'est vrai c'est après oui quand
on leur dit oui qu'on a déjà fait des
stages donc là donc il se pose la
question il nous demande et on leur dit
bah qu'on était là donc depuis ça fait
quelques mois avant que au début il nous
suivent dans les couloirs tu connais
t'étais là qu'est-ce que tu as fait
j'étais en face c'est quoi et puis on
leur explique après du coup il dit mais
tu dois connaître plein de choses bah
non enfin ça vous sert peut-être aussi
cette expérience que vous avez
auparavant tout à l'heure vous me disiez
aussi quand on prépare l'entretien ces
étudiants sont beaucoup plus motivés
peut-être que les autres quand ils
viennent dans ces filières ils viennent
parce qu'ils ont véritablement envie de
les suivre et ils vont pas décrocher ils
vont rester attentifs ça vous a servi
ces expériences que vous avez eu avant
certaines
par rapport au stage c'est vrai que
c'était très
très bénéfique pour là les stages qu'on
a fait aussi au début pour les courses
c'était un petit plus elles sont
beaucoup plus motivées les étudiants en
général sont beaucoup plus que les
autres ce sont des vraiment des
étudiants qui restent jusqu'au bout des
deux des deux ans de formation et qui
sont véritablement motivés parce que moi
on a toujours des étudiants qui viennent
en début d'année et qui ne savent pas
forcément en quoi consiste le BTS
Tourisme ouellerie donc là en
l'occurrence pour ces étudiants là c'est
pas le cas donc
ce dispositif passerait 3 mois de mise à
niveau comment se déroule ces trois mois
donc c'est une alternance de cours et de
stage avec deux semaines de cours pour
démarrer un mois de stage deux semaines
de cours et trois semaines de stage
c'est très recherché c'est très demandé
parce que là vous recevez les dossiers
vous nous l'avez dit jusqu'à ce weekend
à peu près après ce sera trop tard
puisque ça débute le 27 mars nous on a
une classe d'environ 18 étudiants donc
on reçoit peut-être
25 ou 30 dossiers enfin ça dépend des
années donc on a quand même pas mal de
dossiers mais bon on peut pas non plus
recevoir beaucoup beaucoup d'étudiants à
la formation
voilà on se limite à 18 parce que il
faut que ça reste encadré voilà ça reste
voilà tout à fait puisque après ces
étudiants là intègrent nos classes de
BTS Tourisme de vitesse hôtellerie
restauration donc on peut pas
faire il faut faire en sorte que y ait
plusieurs profils qui puissent intégrer
nos classes quoi que ce soit pas que la
passerelle qui soit après voilà vous
vous imaginez où après la suite pour
vous moi plus dans le tourisme culturel
en tout cas un peu événementiel aussi
moi je pense loin
le tourisme loin au soleil peut-être
sûrement et sûrement dans un tour
opérateur vous même dans un réceptif
donc à l'étranger voilà mais ce
dispositif passerait vous nous avez dit
c'est assez rare c'est le seul
établissement celui de Guyancourt elle
propose
il faudrait vérifier parce que peut-être
que depuis il y en a une un autre mais
donc on est parmi les seuls à le faire
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que même
pour les élèves de tourisme par exemple
elles ont pu durant ces trois mois avoir
des cours de cuisine des cours de
restaurant donc c'est très diversifié
puisque les profils sont divers donc
même les élèves qui se destinent à faire
du tourisme mais touche un peu à la
cuisine aussi donc c'est intéressant je
pense et vous pourrez découvrir tout ça
lors de des portes ouvertes ce sera le
23 février 9h30 16h comme on vont se
dérouler ces portes ouvertes il y a pas
que cette formation cette filière a
découvert c'est l'ensemble des
formations qui se présentent voilà donc
il y a des espaces d'information
visiteurs ou les professeurs renseignent
vraiment au détail les les personnes qui
viennent les les jeunes ou les parents
qui viennent se renseigner et puis il y
a beaucoup d'animations qui sont mises
en place par les élèves d'hôtellerie de
restauration et de tourisme et avec
aussi un déjeuner locavore au restaurant
qui est proposé aux visiteurs donc avec
des produits exclusivement du du coin
donc de la Vallée de Chevreuse notamment
donc ça c'est après c'est la petite
surprise ce sera le menu avoir à
découvrir sur place et les portes
ouvertes ça fonctionne bien les
étudiants viennent de plus en plus
nombreuses qui attire toujours on a
beaucoup de beaucoup de monde chaque
année donc il y a beaucoup de des élèves
de tourisme ont préparé beaucoup
d'animations et également d'hôtellerie
et de restauration donc avec des des
démonstrations en hôtellerie en cuisine
aussi donc il y a beaucoup de choses à
découvrir à cette occasion les journées
portes ouvertes 23 février 9h30 16h
merci à tous les trois et puis pour ceux
qui voudraient des renseignements sur
ces différentes portes ouvertes et puis
sur la filière le dispositif passerait
le rendez-vous sur le site internet qui
s'est affiché et puis également en
numéro de téléphone pour avoir beaucoup
plus d'informations merci encore
éducation toujours à prendre l'anglais
dès le plus jeune âge c'est devenu une
évidence preuve en est l'affluence lors
des portes ouvertes de la nouvelle
antenne des Petits Bilingues c'est une
société et qui est implantée dans une
cinquantaine de villes en France elle
vient d'arriver à Élancourt Anthony Rey
chez Élodie moine
la langue anglaise chaque groupe de
travail constitué de 6 à 12 enfants
maximum à Élancourt les activités
débuteront au centrales et Guy Boniface
à partir des vacances scolaires de mars